for the first time since September
Chinese intelligence officers are
accused of stealing information from
American corporations ten Chinese
intelligence officers hackers and
company insiders face espionage charges
a federal indictment unsealed yesterday
accuses them of conspiring to steal
commercial jet engine technology for
more than a dozen companies Jeff Pegues
is in Washington with the details of
this important investigation Jeff good
morning good morning this latest
indictment adds to the growing tension
between the US and China in the middle
of this fierce trade war federal
prosecutors say the Chinese officers
tried to steal coveted information on
turbofan engine technology while they
were working to develop a similar engine
for their commercial planes at lists 13
companies as targets of the operation
with offices located in France the
United Kingdom and eight cities here in
the US the hackers allegedly used
several tactics including injecting
malware into the company's computer
systems in a statement a US attorney
accused China of trying to steal the
information for commercial gain saying
that China could use the information to
build their own engines instead of
buying American fionna Jeff a really
important story you're bringing to us
thank you